foreign
[Music]
oh that's lovely
hey everybody
hope you're all doing well
um
I hope I am being heard and seen all
right I'm sure I'll find out in just a
moment
ah
it is too eggnog thank you very much
doesn't mean it's only eggnog but that's
a whole other conversation now isn't it
hope everyone is doing well
I'm heading into
a crazy month I have a I have a show
this weekend I have two shows the
weekend after that holidays are coming
up
I think I'm done my holiday shopping
which means that in a few days I will
Panic remember that oh crap I meant to
get blah for whatever and
Panic buy more stuff but in theory I'm
done reality of probably not I just
don't know what I've forgotten yet
uh I enjoyed your contribution to one
brilliant scene oh thank you man that
was fun I was I I was glad that uh that
everybody got together to to do that
kind of thing again
um because that that was that was just
fun and I I honestly
um
could have easily gone with some other
options there were some decent choices
but I'm happy with the one I picked
isn't eggnog already alcoholic uh not
necessarily store-bought eggnog
generally isn't unless you're buying it
from a liquor store
three well it's it's uh it's three
numbers carowind I think I know we
talked before I think I miscommunicated
that I've got two shows but three
numbers because one of the shows I have
two numbers to do
and then the other one uh I have I have
a number to do at least I think that's
what's going on now I'm Panic now I'm
panicking wondering about that
hang on
and then I yeah I think I think it's
just the two shows it's three numbers
it's the two shows I think
all right hopefully I'm on top of that
I'm gonna have to double check some
stuff
um do you watch has been hell of a boss
or zoophobia I am aware of has been
hotel and hell of a boss I've not heard
of zoophobia I have not watched any of
them
despite having a burlesque number that
is that uses a song that was inspired by
a character from I think hell of a boss
I don't know but I I've yet to actually
uh watch it remember last year I was at
work and had to put a date on something
and thought oh crap only two weeks till
Christmas oh
don't know if you saw mine went with
Ryan and Graham's departure plugs to the
chat oh yes I did see that one that was
a good one I like I I figured you I like
I remembered you had done one but I had
a blank trying to remember who did what
so I I wasn't able to shout it out
myself so thank you for doing so
I love the weird review just looked at
the trailer could immediately tell what
they were doing spinal tap 2.0 or the
ruddles yeah pretty much
um oh yes oh my gosh Carolyn you're
right I did completely forget the third
thing
yep
oh thank goodness I have you oh my
goodness thanks so much for that
um but yeah weird weird is a good time
um
is eggnog just like an optionally
non-alcoholic Advocate I don't know
maybe I don't know
I listened to your last episode of the
tough like a girl podcast I hope people
um enjoyed that I think I think we had a
good run but it was
logistically it was becoming untenable
and I think we had kind of
we we were slowly losing Steam on it and
it just it seemed like a better idea to
um sort of wrap it up and and bow it out
before it really started to feel like an
obligation that we weren't enjoying
anymore so
um 71 episodes though I think that's a
decent run for a podcast a monthly
podcast at that
I think that's that's pretty solid in my
book
I watched the second trailer for The
Super Mario Brothers movie ah crap
that's out today
oh I'm gonna have to shoot a reaction to
that after the Stream
dang yep yep you gotta gotta put that on
my to-do list
um do I think uh any other doctors will
appear in the 60th I doubt it
um Christopher Eccleston won't work with
um with RTD so there's zero chance of
that Matt Smith really doesn't seem
particularly interested he hasn't even
agreed to do big finish stuff so I don't
see him coming back anytime soon
similarly with Peter Capaldi
um and I I feel like most will feel that
they got their classic fix with power of
the doctor so I am not expecting any
other doctors to show up for the 60th uh
specials
new Vera would rock ruddles yes I did I
did know what that is I've actually
never seen the ruddles but I do know
what it is
uh
sorry the saw the proper Mario trailer
I'm worried it seems to feature too much
well I'll I'll let you know what I think
after I do it what made you change it as
Oppo apparently used to be punch like a
girl oh
uh so
there's a story behind that a black
cover so
there's a gym
I guess in
um
I think it was Arizona
where the gym the business that runs the
gym is called punch like a girl
and they threatened the network the
podcast network with legal action for us
using that name
for the punch like a girl Comics podcast
and we tried to explain to them that
that's not how copyright works because
you registered a gym business in Arizona
this is a
this is a not-for-profit
entertainment podcast
you know operating out of a network that
is based on the East Coast
this your copyright for your business
doesn't
we're not conflicting with that like the
only the only issue where there was
possible crossover is
um I think at the time we might have had
available
um to buy like the the show logo on a
t-shirt which obviously I said punch
like a girl we said like we'll get we'll
take that off the merge and so like that
that should clear that up like there's
zero confusion nobody's gonna confuse
what we do with what you do
um but
they they did not um they did not care
that they didn't understand what
copyright and trademark actually is are
so
um they continued to threaten
um legal things rather than be you know
reasonable human beings and we just uh
we just changed the title because even
though we knew we were right it wasn't
worth it it was stupid so it just
changed the title and changed the logo
and called and called it a day
there was some evidence that 11 will at
least make will at least be referred to
in the 60th if not make an appearance
tweet by the director included a bow tie
Emoji I mean a reference I wouldn't be
surprised I would be shocked if he
appears
I like him flatly I would be very
shocked
uh in anything other than like archive
footage
um which like is possible that's how
they got Eccleston in for like one quick
shot in The Day of the Doctor was a
piece of archive footage so like that
maybe
um
but yeah I'm not expecting him to to
actually show up
I think the ruddles is on here it used
to be at least George Harrison makes a
cameo as a reporter oh that's cool
I'm Nifty oh hey Meg good to see you
am I going to see Strange World
um I don't know
I need to like I'd
I would like to see it
for everything I've got going on I don't
care enough about it to rush out to the
theater
but if my kiddo is interested in seeing
it
I don't know if she even knows what it
is but I'll show her a trailer and if
she's interested I might go with her if
not I'll just wait for it to hit
streaming Supreme
Omega thank you very much for the Super
Chat it is greatly appreciated even
though I dislike Red Hood post-crisis
pre-resurrection Jason Todd is not a bad
character he wasn't The Bad Seed but a
troubled yet good boy
I
I don't
think that Jason Todd
um pre-resurrection so like back when he
was dead and he just had his stretch uh
as Robin I don't think he was a bad
character
I do however think that him being dead
made for better stories than him being
alive
I I feel comfortable saying that
ah
snazzy and cute oh snazzy thank you mag
thank you very much
a third series of his dark materials are
coming soon I can't wait well I hope
that you enjoy it I I could I couldn't
get back into that after I did the
episodes I was commissioned for
what was my initial reaction to seeing
the classic doctors and power of the
doctor or was I at all surprised did you
jump in your chair personally I started
dancing I was surprised uh I was
absolutely surprised by that and I got
more excited with each one so initially
we see David Bradley first I think I was
like okay cool they brought him back
Nifty and then we saw Peter Davis and
I'm like oh that's cool and then we saw
Colin Baker I'm like oh oh please tell
me that's not it and then we had and
then we had Sylvester when Sylvester
McCoy showed up that's when I got really
excited and then Paul McGann I'm like so
like each one kind of built uh the way
that that really it did get me excited
ah
my nails are pretty well some of them
aren't even painted so like I'm I need
to finish these off for this weekend
um I'm doing I'm doing a sparkly green
on these I'm doing a sparkly red on
these so you know green and red holiday
more coordinated than I normally uh
would do them
do I have any plans to do best 13 or
chibinal pend episodes uh I have
something planned with a bunch of people
for this Friday plugin intensifies
um eventually when I when I finish
when I finish my take two review on
um
on the chiminal era I will I expect I
will do a 10 bet you know
hopefully 10 uh best episodes of the era
um whether I'll do a separate list for
the best gymnopend episodes maybe that
would largely just be dictated by
whether or not I would be including
stuff outside of the time period when he
was a showrunner which I probably would
because I think most of the scripts were
better
um
speaking of the 60th anniversary just
been listening to the big Finnish
adaptation of doctor when the star Beast
comic the one with beep the Meep oh God
Doctor Who's weird man
that's real weird
going back to my is eggnog uh avocad
question avocad is a sweet egg-based
liqueur with a custard like consistency
does that sound familiar yeah that
basically sounds like eggnog
um except eggnog does not necessarily
have alcohol so like this as it comes as
as I buy it is alcohol free
um I don't know if this is truly what is
traditionally added but I am used to
having rum added to it
laser has their own album laser laser
has been up to some cool stuff uh laser
from the double clicks if folks don't
know
anyone here watching Avenue 5 on HBO Mac
I Max I'm enjoying it trying to peer
pressure V into watching it
sneaky woman
what do I think of sneaking lgbtq plus
books into conservative libraries and
just leaving them on the shelves
um
honestly
it's
I don't have a problem with it I don't
think you shouldn't do it
but it's kind of petty and it's unlikely
to ever get acknowledged and I'm not
above being petty
don't get me wrong
uh but like it's one of those things
like you're probably never even gonna
know if if somebody found it and was
bothered by it and I just I don't know I
have a hard time getting
into a headspace where that makes much
sense or hold much appeal for me
personally
do I remember Fame because we recently
lost Irene Cara I know what Fame is
I have never seen it
I just made hot berry Crystal Light with
boiling water and add Vodka it's warming
it's warm tasting and hydrating that
that sounds interesting
rank the doctors from least Daddy slash
Mommy to most daddy slash Mommy
[Laughter]
oh dear
oh dear now part of my brain is going to
be thinking about that the rest of the
Stream
uh Supreme Omega thank you very much do
you dislike uh that adaptation still use
Babs as Batgirl even though Killing Joke
is problematic I prefer her as Oracle
one a few disabled reps and Comics
so
I have very mixed feelings about the
fact that the comics
um put Babs back in
the back in the outfit
for the one um for the first thing that
actually did get some decent stories out
of that largely because they Gail Simone
writing it at least initially and
um so
I the reason Barbara ended up in a
wheelchair was kind of BS but that what
happened with her as Oracle was the was
the absolute epitome of making
um lemonade out of lemons
so it was a bit of a shame for that to
go away and
you know
it is a little bit odd that
depending on what bit of Batman you take
in you could get any number of robins it
actually seems like these days most
adaptations favor Damien Wayne being
Robin and
um Dick Grayson being established as
Nightwing and having that as part of his
past
um but like if they do backer let's
always Barbara
it's always Barbara
um and it's never any of the other
people I mean Cassandra Kane's the main
one that I'm like can we like I love the
birds of prey movie don't get me wrong
and I even like the character of
Cassandra Kane and that but that
character is not Cassandra Kane I'm not
entirely sure why they called her that
honestly they could have called her
Stephanie Brown and it would have made
more sense
so yeah and but at the same time like
we've had some decent interpretations of
Batgirl I like the Batgirl that's in the
the Harley Quinn animated movie not
movie TV show
oh uh Michaelson Anderson Doyle Dharma
thank you for the
renewed membership much appreciated
forgive me for bringing this film up but
avocad is what Grady accidentally spills
on Jack in the Gold Room
oh shining okay whatever
will start streaming tomorrow am I gonna
watch it I am I'll definitely review the
premiere episode I'm not gonna make a
promise
um
you know in terms of sticking through
the whole thing it depends on how I feel
about it if I feel I have much to say
episode to episode but I'll definitely
be reviewing the first episode
Palm again is definitely most daddy by
my measure
I'm not gonna necessarily sign off on
that as a definite but you can certainly
make the argument
um of him being
most Daddy
the things I get to say on here
[Music]
let's see
I'll sum up Avenue five for you it's
house but in space just because it has
Hugh Laurie doesn't mean it's like house
the impression I got from it didn't seem
like it was
my favorite endless I've been reading
Sandman I just finished brief lives I
really like destruction I like
destruction a lot I like delirium a lot
honestly I like most of them for
different reasons I like desire because
desire is fun as a character uh
they're not a good person but I do like
them as a character I like death
that's that's an easy answer I like
delirium I like destruction you know
Destiny's just kind of bland and despair
unfortunately doesn't get as much to do
as I would like
but I like most of them
to have a favorite I don't know
kind of gravitate towards delirium I'm
not gonna lie
Capaldi is Daddy argument to be made
there as well
Ellie Webster thank you very much for
the Super Chat
hey Vera sorry to ask but would you mind
if I cited your book skirting gender and
the bibliography for an essay I'm
writing for my masters should by all
means go for it
consider this my uh officially
um approving of citing my book skirting
gender
in Ellie Webster's
um
essay for their masters cheers
I did watch the Guardians of the Galaxy
special I've also shot my review for it
it'll be up
later this week probably
um but I have seen it
well this doctor ranking has turned into
a conversation oh boy I feel like
I feel like five might be the least
Daddy if I'm being honest
um
Capaldi's pretty Daddy
three
John Pertwee John pertwee's pretty Daddy
hmm
[Music]
I'm back I'm here I'm okay
ah
what am I eating I'm eating raspberries
uh remember when you say you throw
something if Spider-Man lost the Oscar
to Incredibles 2 that's what I will do
if Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio loses
to Disney Pixar I need to add that to my
to-do list because I that I haven't
gotten to
Miss
Y is Mom Miss Missy is
Missy's very Mommy
Missy is a chaos Dom this is like I
don't know if that's an actual thing but
I feel like that oh boy
just a look when she gets in her face
when she's like
say something nice
huh
oh
here
because it feels hot in here
um
what's the worst Christmas movie I've
ever seen
um
I don't know there aren't that many bad
Christmas movies that I've seen or at
least that I paid attention to I've like
I've been in the room as bad Christmas
stuff was playing but didn't pay
attention
probably the worst Christmas movie that
I like sat down in a theater and had to
pay attention to
was probably last Christmas
which I have a review on ranting about
because I couldn't believe that damn
thing
oh boy
Joe Martin that's all I'm gonna say
potentially I'm gonna I would put that
one on hold pending like I really want
to hear her dig into the part on big
finish but maybe
maybe she's a real cool person too
will I be covering Disney's Strange
worlds and the News around it
um if by news you mean the fact that
it's tanking
um I don't really intend to
I have a feeling that it's the kind of
thing that it like stick a pin in it is
going to show up in another discussion
um I doubt I'll I will have a video
dedicated to it unless there's something
that's gone on with it that I'm not
aware of
13 is more of a beloved older sister
than a mommy yeah 13 does not really
have mommy energy
always remember when it comes to Daddy's
Dargo is Daddy oh Darko is so Daddy
all right Dargo tell him tell him whose
daddy is I'm your Daddy yeah that's
right darko's your daddy
[Music]
who
uh
see
is Home Alone 2 better than the first
no I thought it was when I was a kid
because the comedy was more ramped up
and the slapstick was more extreme it's
not though the first one is a better
film
River song has mommy vibes
yeah yeah
she does
I like that this is a recurring thing
that's gonna keep coming up in the chat
for this whole thing oh uh oh God Last
Christmas I realized the pun right
before you explained it and I couldn't
stop laughing I know I still
I still can't believe that that was the
actual premise of that movie I
it boggles my mind that that was
that was the movie
oh God
that's that's still
oh that's still so weird to me
I can't even think of daddy as anything
but a sexual thing anymore
I mean like I have the benefit of
um
of both of the terms both daddy and
mommy not being ones that I ever used
even as a kid those that's not what I
called
um the parental figures in my life so I
thankfully don't have any weird
associate any weird associations but yes
as a result it's hard for me to hear
either one and not have at least part of
my brain go
in a Direction
which is uh
unfortunate this is what the internet
does to us
uh
last Christmas let's take a George
Michael line extremely literally make a
movie out of it yeah
yeah
Krampus was a lot more fun than I
expected yeah I mean that was a fun
viewing time
can I quote something from A Christmas
Story I could quote a lot of things from
A Christmas Story
sure yes I can
any interest in reviewing Don't Hug Me
I'm Scared the TV show not especially
um I appreciate that it's the kind of
thing that lots of people do enjoy
um it's not really my type of thing you
know I I I've I've seen videos about it
and I've seen little bits and it just
makes me think of things like um like a
lot of
um a lot of Adult Swim stuff that that
went
dark or stuff like salad fingers and I
just like I appreciate that stuff but I
don't especially enjoy it
so not not high on my list to watch on
my own I mean if somebody wants to
commission it they can
a doll like Emperor has problematic
daddy vibes
the Dalek Emperor is a frustrated Dom
because he thinks that just by virtue of
having that voice people will listen to
him
but the Ninth Doctor is a brat
and so it's just not working
I just basically rewrote that entire
climax of series one didn't I
oh dear
I mean the fact that you have the doctor
going no I said no like it's it's it's a
big brat moment
I'm the Home Alone thing I should say
the first one is better but the music is
Sensational in two I mean the music's
good in both uh I haven't rewatched the
second one in a long time so I'm not
sure
where I'd catch the differences but it's
I mean like it's probably amped up a
little bit
the Starship Titanic enough said I ah I
should reread that book
that was a good book
I'm very surprised
that they never bring up that the film
is set in 2017
the Christmas after George Michael
passed
you're right
huh that didn't occur to me
do you have any idea why the American
Christmas music Canon is largely stuck
in the 60s while the British Christmas
music Canon is stuck in the 80s
um
well I think
I think in the U.S people just stopped
trying to make new uh Christmas Staples
I think the last one that made it was
Mariah Carey All I Want For Christmas Is
You
and after that people kind of gave up
the thing is the UK always had the the
Christmas number one as like a thing
that's not a thing in the U.S
so there really just isn't much
incentive to try and come up with new
stuff and there hasn't been
um yeah we had little periods of people
trying to
um trying to come up with new stuff but
for the most part at this point
everyone's just throwing their hands up
and gone
I I guess we're just gonna do covers of
the old stuff
I mean like it like you'll get albums
where somebody will do like one or two
original Christmas songs but it's like
it's not going to get released as a
single they're not going to try and make
a thing out of it
what's my favorite sci-fi movie for me
it's The Fifth Element I know crazy
Choice element did I say elephant
yeah uh
I don't
I don't know if I have a single
favorite
um sci-fi movie that I can because I
like sci-fi kind of too much as a genre
to just boil it down and go that
that one because there's just so many
you know whether it's
Blade Runner or alien or rival there's
just
I mean I I would personally argue
um that the fountain is sci-fi
there's just there's a lot of good stuff
I don't think I could pick just one
uh 255 A.D thank you for the Super Chat
have you ever watched kids next door no
I did not I'm assuming you're referring
to the cartoon I'm familiar with it I
wasn't really following too many new
cartoons at the time that came out the
Sasha Dewan Master have Daddy vibes no
he's not in control enough to have
proper daddy vibes
um so no I I would say not
I remember Alex Kingston was kind of an
Awakening for me when she was on ER mind
you I didn't realize what she was
Awakening but she was her and Juliana
margulis
solid that yep that uh
that
works
uh Johnson master and World enough in
time has massive daddy Vibes yes I have
issues that specific one yes earlier in
car earlier instances of his master not
so much
Supreme Omega thank you for the Super
Chat my big issue with Babs back girl
again is that Cass and Steph have been
done dirty a lot DC tried to turn Cass
evil and tried to horrifically fridge
stuff by having her be tortured and
possibly assaulted yeah yeah now like
thankfully both those things got rolled
back because of fan outrage because it
was BS in both cases this is
I feel like this is honestly kind of a
big problem at DC in a way that it isn't
at Marvel I feel like whenever
um for the most part for the most part
in Marvel when there's a character that
a writer doesn't want to work with or
who doesn't or they don't get or the
editorial like like we don't want to
work with this character
they just back bench them
you know they just they just use them
less they don't feel the need to destroy
something the way that DC frequently
does with everything from what from
turning characters evil to killing them
to literally erasing them from time
DC it almost feels vindictive at times
what it puts its fans through Marvel for
the most part again there are exceptions
ah brand new day but
um for the most part Marvel
if they're not properly utilizing
something or a writer doesn't have an
idea for a character they'll just
they'll just back bench them
they they won't they won't do something
horrifying to them
as a rule
what do I think of the Christmas Prince
movies I recently watched Johnny
Nicholson's review Liz has seen those
they're part of her uh her trash holiday
viewing
uh listens to beer talk about the Dalai
Kemper being a frustrated Dom finally
the hard-hitting critical analysis I've
been looking for
uh
uh I could very much go through Doctor
Who and just give a BDSM Dynamic read on
a whole lot of things
uh just typed gargoyles into rule 34
sites specifically to find Goliath
xanatos images all I can tell you is so
far that so many people fancy Brooklyn
apparently yep Brooklyn uh
uh Brooklyn kind of had the Swagger
going uh in that so I'm not super
surprised
uh good luck in your hunt
it reminds me I need to dig out my
Michael Buble in 80s Christmas CDs good
choices
excuse me
uh if a movie or show is the slightest
glimpse of sci-fi I throw it in the
Sci-Fi category just because I want so
much sci-fi everything must be sci-fi
sci-fi is a potentially very
far-reaching uh genre depending on how
you want to define it
um and like
you you could if you wanted Define most
superhero
uh stories as sci-fi because most of
them feature technology that doesn't
exist
13 is more like a loving adopted mother
a little bit
uh
I want to set Bendis on fire for a brand
new day Bendis was not brand new day
uh was he no that was still JMS I am
pretty sure
uh hold on
uh uh
oh actually so actually I had the name
wrong brand new day that specific
storyline was Dan's slot but it was
following on from one more day which was
J Michael strasinski
who's a great writer who's done some
great stuff but
[Music]
255 A.D if I commissioned another
culture novel that's not available in
audio format in the US how long would I
have to wait uh I don't
uh I won't do it if it's two years again
um
it is hard for me to
give you something more definitive than
that I wouldn't want it to be that long
away either let's be really clear about
that but
um between the catching up I still have
to do with commissioned stuff and how
long it would take me to read a physical
book
um
you
realistically you'd probably be looking
at a year
before I would get to it
hopefully not longer than that but it's
difficult for me to make
um a strong promise
because obviously I have my goals my
intentions and then there's
reality
on a BDSM analysis of 60s BBC TV have
you ever seen any of the original
Avengers uh I have not
but
um I'm very aware of Mrs peel
whoo
hmm down down Steed down
uh
uh I keep coming back to Keith David as
Omega Matt Berry as the monk do I know
who Matt Berry is hold on
I I feel like I know that name but I'm
drawing a blank
here
Matt Berry
um oh okay
so I've like I've seen him just in the
very basic sense
I haven't watched any of the stuff he's
well known for
um maybe I guess
have I seen the new Interview with the
Vampire series if so why is it the best
series you've ever seen I haven't seen
it
I haven't had time it's too much stuff
I'm trying to catch up on
worst Christmas flick in my opinion the
old Tin Soldier one with Laurel and
Hardy God it's awful I never saw that
imagine if the Muppets did more classic
literature like the prince of the Pauper
or Oliver Twist I would like to see The
Muppets do Shakespeare
I I wanna I wanna see the Muppets
Macbeth
I want to see Miss Piggy as Lady Macbeth
and Kermit as Macbeth
um
Sam would be the king that they kill
Ed who would be McDuff
Gonzo Maybe
that could work
I must ask how are you I am all right
I'm okay
um
favorite Christmas record I don't know
uh
let's see have you ever listened to the
Christmas song called the Christmas
shoes uh yes I have
I don't
I don't understand
I I don't get it
a lot of the Civil War [ __ ] in
regards to Reed Richards is JMS also and
yes I'm totally with you on that
uh
Reed Richards is a hard character to get
right because he's very much a product
of the time when he was originally
written which was the 60s he was
basically Father Knows Best of the
superhero world and it's hard that
doesn't work played straight anymore and
it's hard to
it's hard to deconstruct that without
just tearing the character down not many
writers have been able to do it
if Doctor Who has reported to have a
much bigger budget where do you think uh
it'd be best for the show to spend the
money bigger effects bigger guest stars
more episodes and spin-offs
um
I'd like to get us back up to 13
episodes per season again that would be
Priority One
I want the Muppets Doctor Who
could have Uncle deadly as the uh as the
master
the guy who plays vinder and Doctor Who
plays the main character in interview
with the vampire's performance is
amazing I've heard that
I've heard that
um and I like I want to see it but I
have not had the time
I have the original Avengers theme song
on iTunes written by a woman oh cool
I'm a bill that came up with that name
when the producer wrote M appeal for the
female partner as in male appeal so
hence Emma Peel yep I did know that
story
favorite Weird Al song
[Music]
probably Yoda
yeah probably
let's see have I seen Life on Mars no
I've not seen either version of Life on
Mars
it seems interesting but no I have not
uh didn't I hear the JMS made original
Shira is that well written I don't know
if he did uh no not especially but I'll
tell you what he did do some writing for
that was better written than it had any
rights to be was The Real Ghostbusters
cartoon
not every episode was great but there's
some good episodes on there and some of
my favorite ones of that show were ones
he wrote so despite him having written
some stuff that I'm like
he does get at least a little bit of a
pass for that
who would be the only human in a Muppets
Doctor Who
actually I would say the doctor have the
doctor be human
everything else is a muppet
either the doctor or the companion one
of those two is the human
so far the only xanotos image I found is
one with him in a car with fox
that is a shame unfortunately rule 34
unless you look up specific characters
has a tendency to skew heteronormative
I'm frustrated because JMS did
really well with this series Rising
Stars like he's done some good stuff but
some of it
ah yeah some of it
not uh
uh not ideal
Muppet dialects oh yo could be the
Daleks
you You remake them to make them look
metal but the uh the like the Martian
things so that instead of you know you
put the the electronic effect on the
voice and so instead of Exterminating
they're just going yeah
as they come for people
oh I'd be here for that I'd be very here
for that is the JMS also largely
responsible for Babylon 5. JMS created
Babylon 5 and wrote most of the episodes
like just shockingly high percentage
were written by just one guy which is
rare for a US show
there are some full episodes of The Real
Ghostbusters on YouTube cool I've got a
box set with the whole dang thing
with regards to the books I with the
book I'm actually considering
commissioning you for Christmas I'm not
sure uh what I should actually do
because there's a main story I care
about and others I don't I don't know
what to tell you with that
that sounds uh sounds like a bit like
the the structure of the thing you're
considering just doesn't necessarily
lend itself I mean you know when you if
if you do
if you want to point out what part
you're most interested in getting my
opinion on I can try and put be sure I
put more emphasis on that but I'll still
end up covering the whole thing
Gonzo is the doctor Zendaya's the
companion uh in The Muppets Doctor Who
uh that's not my personal thing guys
that's the most likely outcome I see
happening that could work
that could work
my pet theory about why the doctor loves
Humanity so much
is that we look like time Lords
especially after the time War we look
like
um
we look like his now lost people
um I mean like that fits that works as
headcanon certainly
have I ever read the Narnia books I read
Lion The Witch in the wardrobe ages and
ages and ages and ages ago when I was a
kid I never read any of the others
do I think Strange World failing will
cause Disney to make even less queer
characters I don't know I think
the bigger tell on that is going to be
how it does on streaming because it's
kind of my expectation and prediction
that it's going to do very well on
streaming
because they didn't
damn thing like at all
so
but when it hits streaming and people
who have it like see the thing like now
she's gonna go like oh I meant I wanted
to see that that looked interesting I
think it'll do much better on streaming
and that'll probably be the recovery and
like because that'll basically prove
that it was their marketing that that
blew it
um I don't know we'll see
I mean especially considering what
little marketing there was
didn't put the fact that there were
queer characters in it front and center
I think you'd have a hard time
making a coherent argument that that's
why it didn't do well it's not like most
people know most people didn't even know
the damn movie was coming out
uh Discord yes uh so I will be back in a
minute
um with
some stuff I need to
go away
um make sure that didn't screw that okay
sorry I had a weird alert I was afraid
to screwed some stuff up all right
going to the Discord which is a patreon
exclusive perk so you want to join the
Council of ease Discord which is used
for many more things than this but also
to get some questions in let's see
um
excuse me
are there any sports
um that you watch as a spectator would
you watch an archery contest for
instance
um I'd probably not I enjoy doing
archery I don't find it that interesting
to watch especially if I'm never gonna
get to go up and show that I'm better
um
the closest thing to sports that I watch
is marble racing I watch yellow's Marble
Runs
um they've got the they've got the
marble League going on right now which
I'm still watching even though my team
didn't qualify this year which was
annoying
but that's that's as close to sports as
I get
how long did you and Jesse squee after
watching the Peter Jurassic video uh the
The Cameo that she had him do uh a while
I mean a lot of it's there if you
you know if if you are again if you are
a patreon supporter that went that went
up for folks to see and hear you know
live reaction to that whole thing
um a fair bit it was
it was real night and like Jesse you
know was very clear to me like I I
didn't I just told him some basic stuff
I didn't tell him to like say that much
or be that heartfelt he just did that
and it was it was really nice it was
really sweet came across as a very cool
guy
a witch Duck Donald Daffy or ducula
uh Howard and Scrooge MC and Scrooge
Mick are excluded see Scrooge would have
taken it
um
nostalgically probably Donald
though Daffy daffy's real close
would you say that the reason Iron Fist
was targeted for cultural appropriation
uh in the sense of people getting mad
about it was because the Netflix series
was indeed not that great while Dr
Strange who does also borrow elements
from
uh Asiatic beliefs was not really
targeted
um as such because this movie was
actually good keep in mind Danny ran
compared to strange I actually spent 13
years in the mystical city of conlon
after being orphaned adopted into the
culture and knows it well while strange
very much does not um
well
the thing is that I think I think
because in in the case of Iron Fist most
of the talk about the cultural
appropriation to my memory happened
before the thing aired
before we knew that it sucked
so I don't think that complaint was
conditional on the fact that it sucked
um I think the reason you didn't hear
more about it afterwards because it was
such a piece of crap it wasn't worth
critiquing Beyond acknowledging it was a
piece of crap uh whereas Doctor Strange
I think it's being good probably did
quiet
um those sorts of voices
I think
I think part of the difference is that
narratively structurally
part of Doctor Strange's thing is that
he is an outsider to these
beliefs these practices that's actually
kind of core
with Iron Fist the fact that he's an
outsider is not nearly as big a deal
especially because like he was basically
completely adopted into that culture at
a young age
so there's much less of a reason to not
just make the character Asian or Asian
American
whereas you can make an argument with Dr
Strange that his outside his Outsider
state is is actually a bit more relevant
in terms of who he is as a person
um
and it would it would be tougher to
manage because even if you made even if
you cast an Asian or an Asian American
actor as Doctor Strange
culturally it is still appropriative
because it still kind of needs to be
someone who was whose life was steeped
in a luxurious American culture turning
to this other place for answers so even
if you
um did some alterations in terms of the
ethnicity of the actor culturally
they're still going to be coming from
that American culture that's it's kind
of too much of a part of the character's
DNA to change
um and so then it becomes more of an
argument of well do we just not do it at
all
um that said uh Doctor Strange was
rightfully called out for the
whitewashing on um
on the Ancient One something that even
Kevin feige has said since like yeah
that we shouldn't have done that
uh what are my thoughts on people who
say they can't stand superheroes but
will go on and on about anime and manga
that are basically just superheroes uh
without being called as such I don't
have too many thoughts because I don't
have conversations with those people I
don't mean that in like a I'm too good
for that
no I just mean like I don't personally
know too many people like that so I
don't have a point of reference so if I
were to try to think about think of what
would that person be it would be this
weird abstracted idea of a human that
might bear zero resemblance to reality
and I'm not gonna have an opinion on
that
um just for my own Comfort I don't I
don't have thoughts on that because I
don't have a proper point of reference
here's the one thing I will say
is that
while you could probably break down
um
and if you were to break down into
bullet points a lot of the nature of
superheroes and a lot of anime and Matt
and manga yes there's a lot of overlap
but like
there's a there's a lot of big
differences in the cultural signifiers
in terms of how that is presented how
these kinds of powers manifest are
presented are used are utilized in
narrative there's enough of a difference
culturally that like yes on paper
human being with
you know exceptional Powers the same in
both cases but like
everything wrapped around that is fairly
different whether or not that's
something articulated by the kinds of
people you're talking about I don't know
I don't know
uh this may just be me
but do you agree with Seth macfarland
stance that science fiction has become
too entrenched in a lot of areas as
being dark and foreboding and people
using it to reflect their own cynicism
without the bright optimistic tone or
leanings personally I'd go with pulp
sci-fi Aesthetics with the skin type
spacesuits and bubble helmets and ray
guns but that's just me
so
um excuse me I
I think that there has been a tendency
for sci-fi to lean into some darker
material uh over the decades partially
because not all aspects of sci-fi but a
lot of aspects of sci-fi that's kind of
what it's built to do
at its core most sci-fi is taking an
idea a piece of technology a concept
that we have now
and extrapolating out what is the
extreme of this if this becomes
ubiquitous if this like if we currently
have this thing that goes from A to B
what happens when it gets all the way to
Z and
a lot of times that can manifest Darkly
depending on what the nature of the
technology is
um sci-fi is very much built to be
technologically and and culturally
commentating
um that having been said
there's still plenty of room to be fun
I'm not gonna necessarily say that there
isn't enough sci-fi that is bright and
optimistic I will say there is not
enough sci-fi out there that's willing
to be silly
because as someone with a
deep love of Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy
and and also Red Dwarf for that matter
Red Dwarf deals with legitimate sci-fi
Concepts and it's ridiculous and
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy if you
actually stop and think about some of
the stuff that's in there it's
mind-bending and it's hilarious
there
I think there was a
uh there's been a a feeling that sci-fi
was supposed to quote unquote grow up
because there was this idea of how
disposable it was back when it was
um you know bubble helmet spacesuits and
monsters and ray guns
that's a lot of that was silly but we
can have it address more deep narratives
without losing all of that it does not
have to be in either or a lot of people
treat it like it is
um it's a little bit it reminds me a
little bit of when we first started
getting superhero movies
um
you know in the earlier 2000s with like
the X-Men movies where they had to make
a joke about yellow spandex because they
sure as heck weren't going to show it
they were they were afraid to just be
the thing they had to be the serious
version of the thing and I do think a
fair number of sci-fi writers are kind
of stuck in that not all of them but a
fair amount all right I am back in the
main chat now
let's see Isaac Wright thank you very
much hey just thought I'd pop in hope
you're doing well thank you Isaac I
appreciate that Meg thank you very much
what do I want for Christmas
huh
[Music]
well uh as far as most folks
um
watching this uh publicly are concerned
uh I have a uh Amazon wishlist it is in
the description of all my videos You
Wanna you wanna check stuff you can give
me stuff off that
um for people who know me better than
that as you do uh
right ah I don't know
I'm really I'm I'm always bad at
at tackling that
question
uh
uh I don't know I'm
part of the reason that I have the
Amazon wishlist is I
I'm bad at thinking well I should just
ask someone for a thing
I'm really like it just
it feels wrong and even when people
flatly ask what would you like me to get
you I don't know what to say
um
yeah I don't know I've got I've got some
weird mental blocks around that
uh
I don't know
uh it's an anthology Banks wrote in the
80s three of them are the culture
Universe I've thought about the
commission but telling you to ignore the
others well
uh doing that would certainly
make it more likely to be done in a
timely manner that's a factor for
certain
um
Isaac Asimov said there are three
essential stories and speculative
fiction or sci-fi if only what if and if
this goes on
that's not bad
there we go
I've come to find I prefer sci-fi or
science fantasy over science fiction
where the Sci-Fi is more visual
aesthetic but the story operates more on
fantasy principles I I can have fun with
with most of it
um
and it's in its various forms
out of the
2950 images I only found one of Goliath
getting restrained by Owen preparing him
for xanatos
oh my
what are my thoughts on Disney plus
Doctor Who Nevers and what three nuance
and ciliary shows would I like to see
bad person to ask
because I have little interest in
spin-offs so I'm not good at pitching
them or saying what I would like them to
be
I yeah
so that's one of those things where like
I I know people like ooh I bet you'll
have a great answer for that and I just
don't
I still owe you a jar of pickles I'll
take it I will happily take it
witch doctor is the biggest brat and why
is it six
yeah easily
easily my goodness
it's weird that Simpsons is on Disney
plus and not Family Guy not really if
you know much about Family Guy
I think it also depends on where you are
it might be on Disney plus outside the
US like on the Disney plus star thing
but in the US that's on Hulu
it's weird I don't know
hey Angus thank you very much for the
superchar supercharge Super Chat
would you want would you have watched
Andor if it was Endor returned to the
Muppet Planet more seriously uh what
would keep your future interest in the
Star Wars universe
my interest uh at this point is just
going to be selective by necessity uh
see you Meg thank you so much for
stopping in
um
like the my
huh my um
what what's calling to me is uh not much
in Star Wars right now
um like most of the stuff that's been
announced I just don't care
I don't care about
um God I can't even think of what half
of it is
um but like most of the Star Wars stuff
that's been announced you just don't
care about I cared about Andor because I
really liked Rogue one and I was hopeful
and I was very happy with what I got a
video on that coming out on Saturday but
um
a lot of what what the emphasis is in
Star Wars right now is just not
where my interest lies
I'm burnt out on the Skywalkers I'm
burnt out on Jedi I'm burnt out on Sith
I'm burnt out on nostalgia
which is you know might as well be the
the name of most of these shows Star
Wars Nostalgia Edition I mean that that
was the Mandalorian here's here's
Nostalgia for all the stuff that wasn't
in the new movies
so
I will continue to check out trailers
for new Star Wars things and kind of
judge on a case-by-case basis I think
that's where I'm at going forward
do I like the 80s Flash Gordon movie
Flash
I've never seen it
what of Doctor Who's going to be in
Disney all the stuff since Eccleston or
everything since the first doctor it is
my understanding that it will be the
modern era
um and that classic will probably still
be on britbox we'll see we don't know
for certain on that
there's one of xanato's enjoying fun
with both Fox and Titania
but excuse me there's also one of
xanatos walking in on Fox and Bronx
I mean
I have little doubt there are plenty of
monster
lovers today that had their interests
first peaked by gargoyles
I don't doubt that but yes Carolyn is
right I should uh I should wrap it up uh
thank you everybody for joining me I
need I need to go sit my butt over there
and um do a reaction to the new Mario
trailer because that's out and
I'm out of eggnog so there we go how
obscene did that just look
oh it's your God
someone's gotta make a gif of that
aren't they
[ __ ] okay anyways thank you so much for
joining me
um I hope that you all have a good rest
of the week
and please remember that you are
beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned